Panzi Hospital
was founded
under very special circumstances.
They were conditions of war.
During the war of 1996, I found myself
as a refugee of Bukavu.
And while I was there,
I noticed something abnormal:
very high rates of maternal morality.
Often these deaths
0:00:36.340,0:00:39.280
were caused by an inability
to perform
simple cesarian procedures.
Women had to travel by donkey
extremely long distances.
I thought we could do something to help them,
but the biggest surprise is that the first patient
we operated on didn't need a cesarian, she was a woman
who had survived sexual violence.
Some of the fistulas that result from sexual violence
are a result of knives or guns
or broken bottles. So those things can cause different amounts of tissue damage
and destruction.
A fistula is just a hole, really. It's an abnormal connection between two
organs where there should not be a connection.
So, for example, a vessico-vaginal fistula- the most common
thing seen over there-
is a connection between the bladder and the vagina so that these women just
constantly leak urine.
They also get recto-vaginal fistula, which is just a connection between the rectum
and the vagina
so that they pass stool continuously. And again, some women
have both.
Today our clinic
treats more than 3,00 women each year.
That's why we call on
different organizations,
especially our collaboration with
HHI (the Harvard Humanitarian Initiative)
We do exchanges of doctors
and experience
to take better care of these women.
The doctors that we send over lecture and teach in the classroom situation
and also go into clinic,
and also the OR to repair these fistulas.
For me
it was an incredible discovery to see
how
women could arrive in
a state of destruction,
of despair,
of abandonment,
of stigmatization, of social rejection.
[Children singing]
But I then see the
strength with which they fight
to rediscover
their dignity,
I think it is
the strength with which they fight to become themselves again,
I think it is their strength that pushes me to do more.